STEPHANIE WONG: All right, look.
Finding your favorite products
and discovering new ones
requires a user interface
that's easy to use,
informative, clear,
and delightful.
Google Cloud users have mainly
used our side menu to navigate.
But with almost 100
products and growing,
it's safe to say our product
list has outgrown the side
menu.
Over time, we have
listened to your feedback.
And some of you have
highlighted challenges
navigating the Console
to explore our products.
We've heard over and
over again that it's
difficult and
time-consuming to scroll
through the long
list of products
and remember what
each one offers.
So that's why we created
a new All Products
page to help you easily navigate
to your favorite Google Cloud
products.
This page showcases all of
the Google Cloud products,
as well as our key
partner products,
in one easy to navigate place.
With one click, you can
discover the right product
that's right for your solution.
The page is organized
into different categories,
including management, compute,
storage, operations, security,
CI/CD, artificial intelligence,
support, and more.
Quickly jump to the
category of interest
through the panel on the left or
you can scroll the entire page.
Then you can click
each product name
to navigate directly to
the product home page.
Each product listing also
includes a short and long
description so you can quickly
understand what a product does
and whether it fits your needs.
This lets you compare
categories at a glance,
saving you the hassle of digging
up product overviews elsewhere.
Under each product,
you'll also find a link
to documentation
and quick starts
so you can understand
it in more depth
and try it out
right away, removing
the extra step of navigating to
documentation in another tab.
To make navigation even easier,
you can pin products directly
from the All Products
page, and they'll show up
at the top of your side menu.
You can also customize
your navigation
by reordering pins
in the side menu.
That way, you can quickly
access your most used products
directly from the
side menu, instead
of scrolling through the panel
or the All Products page.
With the new All Products page,
you can save time scrolling
and cut straight
to the good stuff--
finding your products,
discovering new ones,
learning, and getting hands-on.
So try it out for yourself by
heading to the Google Cloud
Console.
Click the side panel and
click View All Products.
Or on the home dashboard,
you'll see a call-out
to try out the
All Products page.
If you have any feedback
about this new experience,
I actually want to hear.
So reach out to me on
Twitter stephr_wong
or on LinkedIn @stephrwong.
See you there.